alors la main que vous êtes très
intelligent donc très tolérant mais
comme tout le monde vous avez vos
limites
alors on va faire une interview à la
limite à la limite avec l idée du parti
communiste pourriez-vous être d'accord
avec le fait que il a fait des crimes au
nom de la tendresse à la limite pour
quel homme politique d'extrême gauche
vous pourriez voter face à un homme
d'extrême droite pour n'importe lequel
à la limite à quelle élection
pourriez-vous ne pas aller voter
aucune à la limite qu est ce que vous
trouvez dutil à josé bové le fait
d'incarner quelque chose qui permet de
le critiquer à la limite
qu'est ce qui vous ferait plaisir si
vous deveniez pauvre d'arrivée d'arriver
à le rester sans souffrir limites
qu'elle combat de ernest antoine
seillière trouvez-vous indéfendable
aucun parce que je les aime beaucoup et
que je pense que c'est un personnage qui
ne correspond pas à son image
c'est un gros déconneur d'abord c'est un
gros déconneur sédatif le plus drôle que
je connais et le et deuxièmement en
réalité c'est quelqu'un qui est pas du
tout l'image du patron de combat qu'on a
bâti mais ça la muse de jouer à st vous
voyez je ne l'a jamais mes amis c'est
bien elle à l'élite qu'elle terrorise
trouvez-vous sympathique tous les
terroristes à demi siècle après la
limite qu'est ce qui peut vous rendre
sympathique pour les smicards le fait
que je pense plus à eux qu'ils ne le
croient quand je dis qu'il faut toucher
à l'état providence pour plus les aider
à la limite pour quelles raisons
pourriez vous décidé de donner tout
votre argent à des pauvres
il en attend que ça paye mes impôts
ouais voilà donc jeune plus la moitié
déjà de mon argent à des pauvres avaient
les beats qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
exciter chez laurence boccolini sais pas
qui c'est limite avec quels hommes
pourriez vous coucher alors là vraiment
ça ne m'est pas venu à l'idée mais c'est
vrai que j'appartiens à une génération
où c'est glam ou sexualité était moins
chic maintenant
mythe qu'est ce qui pourrait vous décidé
d'arrêter d'écrire la mort à la limite à
quelle élection pourriez-vous vous
présenter deux papes est la limite pour
quel homme politique de droite
pourriez-vous voté bayrou parce qu'il
est droite
ouais et toi à la limite pour que l'âme
de droite une beauté alors là moi je
suis capable de citer un mec de gauche
pour parler d'un et 2 droite tellement
je les connais est la limite avec
quelles idées du front national vous
pourriez d'accord le pen a dit très
souvent que
setti dit c'était idiot de faire des
bombes nucléaires et donc de préparer la
bombe atomique alors qu'on ne prévoit
pas d'abris antiatomiques la raison est
la limite justement qu'est-ce que vous
aimez bien chez le pen il a ses dents
dans un monde où l'art oratoire ce père
l'art du tribun il ya une époque puis
maintenant mais une époque où
incontestablement d'éloquence oui enfin
bon tribun mon batteur d'estrade
on peut pas nier la limite par qui sait
vous ferez plaisir d'être traité de con
way
non non pas faire beaucoup de choses sur
jean françois kahn n'est pas qu'il est
con vas y avait des chiens non peut pas
dire est que les chiens parce qu'il est
toujours intéressant depuis que je pense
en parisis connaît son sujet il aime ce
qu'il dit j'aime la chanson et en plus
je parle beaucoup de la chanson avec
florent
qu'est ce qui vous ferait plaisir si
vous deviez un jour aller en prison
bah là que la bouffe soit bonne mon
angoisse si je vais en prison c'est la
bouffe est la limite qu'elle terrorise
trouvez-vous sympathique limite jean
moulin moi bien les limites
jean-françois oui à la limite qu'est ce
qui pourrait vous exciter chez claire
chazal
ben vous tous hors jeu alors je prends
souvent je dis pas il y a un côté
écouter le type petites ou moyennes
bourgeoise bcbg avec la mise en plis etc
ça m'excite rien de mal à sa femme n'est
pas du tout comme il vient de décrire
sicile est la limite
avec quels hommes pourriez vous coucher
bruce willis au hasard je ne pourrai
coucher avec un homme que si c'était
d'abord déguisé en femme
ah et bien opérer même sa fille marie v
avant ça peut arriver
ah bon jean-françois non mais c'était ça
fait très longtemps c'était en turquie
dans un bar s'est bien passé
non non non non je comprends pourquoi
oui à l'europe ne sait maintenant
c'était avant rachel j'espère non non ça
fait très longtemps j'ai été dans un bar
en turquie et il y avait une fille que
j'ai fait a priori jolies filles avec
une voix grave pourquoi je fais mais
beaucoup je trouvais très exitant sa
voix grave a pas hésité et on ressent je
me suis aperçu un temps c'est un homme
très vite
quel jeu de mots sur cannes vous aimez
bien et je crois que la festival si
j'étais curé l'abbé cannes en incarnant
bécane dakar hockey à la limite quel
point commun qu'ils avaient avec jef k
regardez j'ai tout je suis beau je suis
jeune on laisse pas le temps je suis
fait peur
j'invite maintenant si c'est pour le
président des états unis
en fait j'ai mal au dos j'ai vu avec la
vraie chose que j'ai en commun efficace
et bien de rester aussi adressé mais pas
le dos maintenant mais même bande
les gens pensent à un public qu'est ce
qui est bien dans le pré des deux choses
alors ça personnellement quand j'avais
des cheveux pas car j'ai eu des cheveux
et j'en ai eu même beaucoup je ne
pouvais pas les coiffer pays peut aller
dans tous les sens exact est ridicule et
j'ai été très content d'être chauffeur
plus ça me donne pour le guen a bien tu
me prépare psychologiquement elle est
limite quelle drogue aimeriez-vous voir
légaliser j'ai longtemps pensé qu' il
fallait légaliser les drogues douces
pour
éradiquer la criminalité il suffit de
voir ce qui se passe en banlieue bon
évidemment si c'était en vente libre ou
y aurait pu les dealers ils auraient pu
le crime organisé il aurait pu etc
le problème c'est que si vous légaliser
les drogues doute tout se répercute
ensuite sur les drogues dures et donc il
ya quelque chose d'absurde c'est à dire
qu'en vérité c'est tout ou rien et dire
qu'il faut tout légaliser peut-être
qu'il faut le faire mais j'hésite à âge
et j'étais allongée à ce soir ne pas
tout de suite là mais bon mardi on peut
la limite de la part de qui un procès
vous ferez plaisir jean-françois houde
d'abord je j'ai j'ai eu et j'ai dû être
mis en examen je suis plus mais dans les
140 145 x est un
about a de la marge au respect alors
justement interview la limite à la
limite
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans le non à
la constitution européenne à limite
c'est que c'est le dire non un super
état européen qui pouvait éventuellement
menacée ouais donc ça c'est la bonne
partie d'une eau pour moi un mythe
qu'est ce que vous trouvez dutil à
olivier besancenot et déjà il apporte de
courrier mais ces quatre ans un monde
assez importante du pride et ils
effraient
il est frais mais franchement penser que
le trotskisme celles à venir du nouveau
monde
j'ai du mal à me faire la limite pour
quelles raisons aimeriez vous que
nicolas sarkozy ne soit pas président
peut-être pour qu'ils puissent être
davantage lui même est un peu moins
accros du pouvoir à la limite qu'elle
combat de ernest antoine seillière
trouvez-vous indéfendable honnête on va
le cdja était pour la suppression du
jour férié de pause lundi paul cottret
jeu des comptes h3c indéfendable quand
même ballet ce truc qui s'est planté il
ya des trucs des triolets relancer pour
est la limite à quelle occasion
pourriez-vous faire un partenariat avec
attaque je peux pas faire de partenariat
avec attaque
pourquoi non je vous expliquais parce
qu'on est dans un pays où ceux qui
connaissent l'économie s'occupe pas des
pauvres et ceux qui s'occupent des
pauvres ne connaissent rien à l'économie
j'aimerais marier les deux états pour
droit dirigez-vous merci à françois
mitterrand lorsque il a résisté très
fortement l'union soviétique vous
souvenez rapport aux manifestations
pacifistes les paires celle les
pacifistes sont à l'ouest les multiples
son talent est à faire donc je trouve
qu'il est il a été il a été formidable
comme chirac sur l'irak est la limite
qu'est ce que le libéralisme engendre de
pire mais je crois que c'est clair
vous avez des comportements libéraux qui
peuvent engendrer l'égoïsme même si j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que le libéralisme
libéral ça veut dire en même temps
généreux et donc en permanence sur nos
chaînes heureux pour soi
non je dis trop tard
vous ne pas dire sa page dédiée trop
tard tout le combat contre la misère au
19e siècle et monnaie par des libéraux
dont pouvait pas dire que c'est l'argent
pour les riches
c'est pas vrai nous vendent aux
chrétiens pas c'est le meilleur mais
mieux règles économiques possibles pour
le meilleur possible partage des
richesses possibles à la limite par qui
ça vous ferait plaisir d'être était de
comprendre
non mais je suis pas sensible à ça
honnêtement je suppose ensuite jamais
indifférent dans un sens ou dans un
autre sens que ça me fait ni des
plaisirs ni plaisir à la dernière
question c'est pas la plus facile à la
matin mais à la limite
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous exciter chez
claire chazal je comprends que vous
réfléchissiez claire pardonne moi ouais
non et vous excite pas non même al alimi
non mais les formidables mais j'admire
son talent à la limite pierre lellouche
pour quel homme politique de gauche
pourriez vous votez dominique strauss
kahn à la limite avec quelles idées du
parti communiste êtes vous d'accord de
défendre la tradition française de la
chasse contre les écolos
ah ça c'est dommage mais il faut que tu
emmènes à la chasse aux coûts aux
électeurs non sans régler à la limite
pour quelles raisons aimeriez vous que
nicolas sarkozy ne soit pas président de
la république seule raison que je vois
c'est qu'il soit heureux en ne l'étant
pas la limite par qui sait vous ferez
plaisir d'être traité de con bernard
debré à ouidah bien des gens connus jean
louis debré la limite avec quels hommes
pourriez vous coucher aucun aucun même
même à la limite même vous je pourrais
dire être même vous maintenant bilal
tout temps du thé tous la nausée relaxe
toi c'est samedi soir
écoute je vais te dire j'ai bien qu'à
paris c'est pas mal mais mais je vais
pas y arriver je suis trop branché bonne
femme
c'est une réalité à la limite pourquoi
diriez-vous merci à françois mitterrand
pour l'alternance parce que je crois que
c'est sain dans une société la peine de
mort aussi pour la peine 2 milliards et
hamé est la limite quel homme politique
de droite décrédibilise la droite
elle a répondu parce qu'il est
fondamentalement il ira de stock
ouais à la limite quelle est la mesure
de bertrand delanoë que vous approuvez
j'approuve
j'approuve paris plages j'approuve les
nuits blanches certainement le sens de
la fête certainement c'est comme une
équipe qui était son vol a fait - ouais
points elle imite pour quelle raison ne
m'auriez vous pas être maire de paris
pour avoir une vie normale
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu